vegas is the massive fireworks show it
is back on the las vegas strip it is a
tradition returning to the valley that's
right you know the pandemic kind of
forced everything to scale back last
year and so it's been a while since
we've been able to ring in with a
full-blown vegas style party officials
this morning are going to be sharing the
details about this year's fireworks
spectacle and hector mejia is joining us
live from the strat where
the sun has now come up so we can kind
of see a little bit more of what's going
on behind you but it's still cold there
hector
it's still cold but you know what makes
it so much better this beautiful view
right behind us looks like the sky and
the clouds are on fire this morning in a
good way as we welcome this new day and
as the city is getting ready to welcome
a new year so as you just mentioned we
get to learn those details later on this
morning and we have video from previous
celebrations previous years obviously a
big draw for tourists bringing in so
many people into town so this year we
get to say hello to 2022
again thankfully with the massive
fireworks show at 11 a.m is when we'll
know exactly how we'll get to celebrate
it we'll learn from the company that
puts on the fireworks spectacular
we know fireworks will fire off from
eight strip locations from the strat all
the way down to mgm grand where we're
live this morning up here at the
observation deck this will be one of the
launching pads and this year it will
include the new resorts world which will
be one of the spots will broadcaster
live countdown to new year's eve 2022
that special will count down to midnight
across all four time zones we'll also
bring you the parties over at the west
gate and downtown with performances from
country star scotty mccreery plus blue
man group cirque du soleil and zoe bowie
and back out here live here's another
view
a magical view of the valley this
morning and in case you were wondering
since we're here at the strat they will
have the indoor sky pot open as an
option for you to watch the fireworks
show you can get a really spectacular
360 degree view of the entire valley and
see all of those
celebrations go on and as far as our
special goes that starts before 9 pm
december 31st so you can ring in the new
year with people at home if that's what
you wish to do reporting live hector
mejia live local now
that's the place to go right warm couch
watch us yeah and everything's free
we're also raising money for food banks
on new year's eve during our program you
can help by using your smartphone scan
the qr code on your screen make a
donation any money you donate sees right
here in las vegas and of course we'll
have the qr code up during the program
as well